so I'm having like a therapeutic moment
at the sex robot Factory I've been in 12
step programs I've been in therapy for
10 years I'm having the most emotional
progress and I've had and I'm talking to
this guy I'm like I don't understand why
people are so against the robots what if
we use the robots to make women's lives
better what if every woman has their own
robot clone think of all the things you
can do with it to make your life safer
before you walk your car at night you
could send it out ahead of you
like a decoy you know how penguins push
other penguins off cliffs you know
like oh oh they got her okay I'm gonna
just
take an Uber
I feel like the sex robots would solve
so many of our problems I keep reading
about gray areas like mixed signals
where two people have sex the next day
the girl feels weird about it but the
guy doesn't understand he thought she
was into it you guys might not know this
but sometimes we have sex with you
before we're ready because we feel
guilty because we've been conditioned to
believe that if we make out with you but
don't have sex with you that your balls
will like explode blue goo all over the
ceiling and then you'll be handicapped
for the rest of your life You'll Never
Walk again so we feel bad and then we
feel ookie the next day if we all have
sex robots that whole dynamic goes away
if you and I make out for 20 minutes but
I'm not ready to have sex with you I can
just say hey look I am not there yet
but
I do have a very flexible piece of
Tupperware in the other room
looks exactly like me without the
ability to criticize you I think you're
gonna love it
so I'm talking about this on stage for a
couple months and people want to come up
to me and argue with me about this very
hardcore this group of people came up to
me and they're like I cannot believe
that you're condoning this what if
people start to mistreat their robots
I don't give a fuck
how about that on my list of shit I have
to worry about that doesn't break the
top 2 000 things
forget about I'm worried
worry the jeans than actual human beings
have you ever seen someone drop their
cell phone in water
[Applause]
said that when they see a starving child
in a television commercial to be like
what else is on
but when there is a phone and water
they're like
when you see the starving child that's
when you should be like
we give food to our phones
so I'm talking to the guy that makes the
robots and I'm like I've thought through
all these arguments I legitimately
cannot think of a reason to be afraid of
the robots and he said this is the real
concern
he said the real concern with the robots
is they're going to get so smart that
they're going to learn to override our
commands I was like oh shit
okay that sounds scary that sounds very
scary and then I was thinking about it
more and I was like wait a second we
already have robots our phones are
basically robots right and my biggest
problem in life is that my phone
actually does what I tell it to I need a
phone that overrides my commands I need
a phone that's like no bitch we're not
going to your ex's Instagram again today
you broke up four years ago overruled
no you're not buying those tie-dye
overall mini shorts you're too old for
that shit reroute to chicos.com
it's what I need